[Music]
Gisele Bundchen seemingly making a big
play stepping out with no wedding ring
amid Tom Brady divorce rumors it gets
harder and harder as you get older
because you do take on a lot more in
your life a new photo shows Giselle
heading to the gym on Tuesday yeah the
most telling detail the absence of her
wedding band something Giselle usually
Sports when she's not on the catwalk not
pictured are the model's workout buddies
her two kids 12 year old son Benjamin
and nine-year-old daughter Vivian
they're just the biggest blessing
this comes as et's learning how the lack
of family time is at the heart of Tom
and Gisele's marital problems which
we're hearing have gotten worse and more
serious she's amazing at her job she's
one of the she is the goat designs
reports of separate divorce lawyers
getting retained and while they did
reunite in Miami last week amid
hurricane Anne Tom and Gisele hunker
down in separate houses
what's up the power couple's estimated
650 million dollar Empires up in the air
and all because of Tom's Infamous
decision to unretire did you just need a
vacation is that what brought you back
there was a little more than that uh but
at the same time
um I took some time away which is always
important it's tough to make a decision
right at the end of the season it's a
big commitment to make for football and
it's not something you just can decide I
needed time and I just figured I'm gonna
go at it again and see what we can
accomplish our source says Giselle feels
like Tom has chosen his career over his
family meanwhile she's got her own
dreams and aspirations which Giselle
doesn't want to keep putting on hold she
really committed so much of her time the
last you know 14 years to make sure
everything was so stable at home so I
could go live my dream
so the first sign their 13-year marriage
was in trouble back in August the NFL
star made headlines after missing
practices it's all personal you know
everyone's got different situations
they're dealing with
and Tom kept his explanation pretty
vague when asked about the time off we
all had really unique challenges to our
life and
you know we're
I'm 45 years old man there's a lot of
[ __ ] going on so you know I just gotta
try to figure out life the best you can
and
um
you know it's a uh
continuous process prioritization I
think has been the key for me as I've
gotten older fast forward to October our
source reveals Tom and Gisele are
weighing their options for the family's
future and thinking about what their
next steps might look like I want to try
to spend my time with when I'm focused
on my job my job when I'm focused with
my family my family and I look back at
my parents and my dad and mom did the
same thing for me so I think what I was
very emotional about is I do feel maybe
some guilt that I haven't been able to
do that in the same way for my kids and
I feel like I'm so driven to succeed in
football and that's taken me away from
other important priorities which are my
kids my wife and she's really held it
down for our family
[Music]